this video is brought to you by talk in
Arabic the only place where you can
learn any of the major dialects of
spoken Arabic if you want to learn
Arabic the way it's really spoken click
the link in the description to visit
talk in Arabic
the Arab world is an extremely diverse
block of countries the thing that unites
them all is that they use Arabic as
their formal written language alongside
a colloquial Arabic dialect the formal
written language is called or Modern
Standard Arabic and is based on
classical Arabic which is also called
the colloquial Arabic dialects are
called ramiya and these differ from
country to Country and even from town to
town one variety of our Mia is Lebanese
Arabic or
Lebanese Arabic is part of the wider
group of levantine dialects and is very
similar to the Arabic spoken by syrians
jordanians and Palestinians but it's
different from Modern Standard Arabic
and different from other dialects to
varying degrees when the Arabic language
spread throughout the Middle East and
North Africa it was adopted by the local
people in each Place who spoke other
languages like tamazict in the maghreb
region Coptic in Egypt and in the Levant
region Aramaic as a result Lebanese
Arabic and other levantine varieties
were influenced by Aramaic as they
developed it's not clear exactly how
much Aramaic influence there was because
Arabic and Aramaic are closely related
Semitic languages to begin with but
there was certainly some influence here
are a few examples the name for Jesus in
Lebanese Arabic is Yeshua which is like
his Aramaic name Yeshua rather than
Arabic Aisa actually I should clarify
that it's normally Christians who use
the Aramaic derived name while Muslims
use the Arabic derived name note that
the number three is used in informally
transcribed Arabic to represent the
letter ayin since there's no Alphabet
letter to represent it the word for
water in Lebanese Arabic is as opposed
to Arabic ma Mai might come from Aramaic
in Old Aramaic water was Maya and in at
least some Modern Aramaic dialects it's
Maye note that the number two is used to
represent a glottal stop known as Hamza
in Arabic the word for hand in Lebanese
Arabic is Eid rather than yet in Arabic
Eid is similar to the word for hand in
modern Aramaic dialects Eda in eastern
dialects and either in Western dialects
Lebanese has a special way of expressing
ability
we can talk Fina is like in us and means
we talk or we'll talk you could Loosely
translate it as it's in us to talk this
doesn't exist in Standard Arabic it
might be from a similar Construction in
Aramaic note that the number seven is
used to represent the sound ha
the vocabulary of Lebanese Arabic was
also influenced by Turkish under the
rule of the Ottoman Empire for example a
word used for room in Lebanese Arabic is
which comes from the Turkish word the
native Arabic word is also used
note the capital D here represents an
emphatic consonant other capital letters
also represent emphatic consonants a
word from maybe in Lebanese Arabic is
both of these come from Turkish
an interjection meaning Bravo or well
done in Lebanese Arabic is afic there is
a standard Arabic word or fak meaning
may God give you health but why does the
Lebanese word mean Bravo that's because
it's associated with
which comes from Turkish meaning Bravo
were well done plus this suffixed
preposition meaning upon you or unto you
you also might hear
though that's obviously not Turkish
the word for lamp in Lebanese Arabic is
lumba which comes from Turkish lamba
which traces back to ancient Greek
lampas after the fall of the Ottoman
Empire and the first world war Lebanon
came under French control with the
French mandate for Syria and Lebanon
this left a noticeable impact on
Lebanese Arabic as well for example a
widely used greeting is
rather than typical Arabic greetings
like Marhaba ahalan or assalamu alaikum
it's sometimes suffixed with the Arabic
object pronounced good morning to you
Paul
good morning to you Elena
good evening to you beautiful ones
to say thank you Lebanese people
commonly say merci rather than shukran
which is more formal and rather than
which means thanks a lot you might hear
so you can see that these French words
are actually integrated into a
colloquial Arabic structure the word
used for toilet or washroom is sometimes
toilet in addition to the Arabic word
the word for pool is sometimes be seen
though the Arabic word is sometimes used
too and so on
not only because of these influences but
also because Arabic dialects have been
developing on their own for over a
thousand years Lebanese Arabic differs
quite significantly from Modern Standard
Arabic as Amia in general do as we look
at some features of Lebanese Arabic
we'll encounter some of those
differences pronunciation the
pronunciation of Lebanese Arabic is
different from Modern Standard Arabic in
numerous ways including both consonants
and vowels for example the Arabic letter
cough which represents the sound
is pronounced as a glottal stop in
Lebanese meaning pen becomes alum
meaning heart becomes alib for a student
of this might seem strange like the
sound just disappears from words there
are some sub-varieties of Lebanese
Arabic which still retain the k sound
such as in the shuf mountains and
wadiyal time area
the interdental fricatives of Arabic are
normally not pronounced in Lebanese
dialect the is replaced by and the is
replaced by the or Z in some words for
example in Modern Standard Arabic the
word for three is but in Lebanese
the word for gold in Modern Standard
Arabic is the while in Lebanese it's the
Hub notice also that the feminine ending
of the Latha the ah sound is much more
closed in Lebanese more like e this is
quite a noticeable feature of levantine
dialects and in Lebanese this vowel
change happens particularly often like
in the middle of the word here
the just sound of Modern Standard Arabic
which is represented by the letter G is
commonly pronounced je like the French J
sound for example the word for mountain
is pronounced Jebel
different words that come from Arabic
like other Arabic dialects Lebanese
Arabic uses some words that are either
not used or not typically used in Modern
Standard Arabic even though the words
have Arabic Origins for example the
usual word meaning to go in Modern
Standard Arabic is while the usual word
in Lebanese is this is actually the
usual verb for go in most dialects even
though it's not in Modern Standard
Arabic the question word meaning Y in
MSA in Modern Standard Arabic is which
translates to for what while the word
for y and Lebanese is
this word itself was not part of
classical Arabic but it comes from the
classical Arabic words Li meaning for
plus a meaning which and she meaning
for which thing or for what is on its
own is the question word meaning what in
some dialects but in Lebanon the word
meaning what is usually it's thought to
have originated from meaning what plus
Hua meaning he or it so again this word
derives from words found in but the word
itself is not part of Lebanese Arabic
and other levantine dialects have a
different way of expressing desire than
Modern Standard Arabic in MSA the verb
meaning want is for example I want is
using a typical verb conjugation but
Lebanese uses a different word but which
has a pronoun suffix I want is but this
is not actually a verb it developed from
meaning in my desire or it's in my
desire but it's fully integrated into
the dialect as an independent structure
as a sort of quasi-verb
what do you want from me word for word
what want you from me this is obviously
not just a difference in vocabulary but
also in grammar there are some other
grammatical features of Lebanese Arabic
that we can take note of to express
ability in MSA the verb is used so to
say I can sing it
I can the singing in Lebanese dialect
the verb is used so I can sing is
I can I sing but in Lebanese there's
also the other way to express ability
that we saw before
it's in me I sing
notice the form of this verb again which
is the first person singular non-past
form of the verb this prefix to the
beginning is something that's used in
levantine Arabic and Egyptian Arabic to
make the verb present tense so I eat
becomes in the present tense but the
prefix isn't used when the verb is
preceded by another verb like in
if this verb was on its own in the
present tense it would be I sing to form
the future tense in Arabic something
else comes before the non-past form the
future marker or the prefix so I will
sing is
a different future tense marker is used
sofa or the prefix
I will sing
in MSA there's no real present
continuous form of the verb the
non-passed form of the verb is typically
used as for the simple present but
Lebanese Arabic has a special present
continuous form using the continuous
marker followed by the present tense so
in MSA he's eating would be
or just yeah in Lebanese Arabic it's
note that the B prefix is optional here
so it could be
um developed from the verb amila meaning
to do or work
now let's look at some more sentences in
Lebanese Arabic and see what we find how
are you Kiefer when said to a male and
kifik when said to a female in MSA this
would be
how condition you're or
how the condition Keith comes from kefir
and the object pronoun suffix is added
directly to the question word
the response to kifak is normally a
typical Arabic response alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah is a slight contraction of
the Arabic phrase
meaning praise be to God notice that the
definite article which is Al in MSA is
pronounced IL in Lebanese Arabic you'll
hear it constantly also note that the
Arabic second person masculine singular
pronoun Anta is pronounced Inta all of
the pronouns in Lebanese Arabic are
similar to those in MSA but slightly
different note that in Lebanese Arabic
there's only one pronoun meaning they
while in MSA there are separate pronouns
for masculine day and feminine they this
is also the case for the plural you
pronouns
another sentence what are you doing in
Lebanese word for word what continuous
marker you do in Modern Standard Arabic
it would be
in some sentences Lebanese Arabic and
Modern Standard Arabic are very similar
but in others like this we see a lot of
differences there's the different word
for what in Lebanese again we see the
present continuous form in Lebanese with
um while the MSA sentence uses the
regular non-past form of the verb we see
the B prefix that marks the present
tense in Lebanese and we can also see
that the verb meaning do is different
both of these verbs are used in MSA but
in MSA amila normally means to work
rather than to do in Lebanese the verb
meaning to work is usually
it's also used in MSA with the meaning
of to be busy or occupied with something
I'm going to the store in Lebanese
Woodford continuous marker I go on the
shop this sentence has the present
continuous form we saw a moment ago but
for verbs of motion it's often more
natural to use a present participle to
indicate present continuous though it's
technically not a verb on its own
I going on the store this is also the
case in MSA
notice the different verb meaning go
also notice the different preposition
Ila which means to or towards in
Lebanese the preposition ah meaning on
is used for verbs of motion rather than
illah and notice the different word for
store duken is also a word in MSA but
it's specifically used for a small shop
or a stall
another sentence I need to buy some milk
in Lebanese
word for word is necessary I buy a
little milk in MSA
is necessary upon me that I buy some the
milk in Lebanese lessim is the most
common way to express need to or have to
as it is in all levantine dialects and
Egyptian with slightly varying
pronunciation it's very simple to use
because it's a non-personal verb so you
don't conjugate it it's simply followed
by the non-past form of the next verb
I need to buy
he needs to buy Etc the word lazim
exists in MSA and means necessary but
it's not the typical way to say need to
or have to this way is more common
instead
plus the subjunctive form of the verb
which is slightly different from the
non-past form like lazim yajibu means
necessary and is a non-personal verb but
the following preposition needs to have
the right pronoun suffix here ya means
me a preposition is not necessary with
lasim
your shoes are nice in Lebanese
you're sweet in MSA
you're beautiful notice the Lebanese
word for sure
which seems to be related to the Spanish
word for Shu sapato the usual MSA word
is either in both Lebanese and MSA the
singular form of the word is used to
refer to a pair of shoes as well notice
the word hello with the meaning of nice
it's the Lebanese pronunciation of the
word which means sweet but can also mean
nice looking but in MSA Jamil is more
common in this context
I don't like them in Lebanese
in MSA
no I like them notice the different
negation marker in Lebanese especially
in urban varieties verbs of all forms
are normally negated with in MSA meh is
one way to negate verbs in the past
tense but for the non-past Le is used
again notice that the Lebanese present
tense has the B prefix if we look at the
non-past forms excluding the B prefix we
see that the two verbs are the same but
there's a difference in vowels then
notice the object pronoun suffix at the
end of both verbs the different pronoun
suffix in Lebanese is thought to be due
to Aramaic influence
the way of negating equational sentences
is also different in Lebanese there's
the word Mish he's not a teacher in
Lebanese
in MSA laser is used
also notice the different word for
teacher istes is the Lebanese
pronunciation of
usted which means Professor but can also
be used as a respectful form of address
like sir or a title for someone with
expertise like sensei in Japanese
another sentence did you see charbell
yesterday this question is being asked
to two people in Lebanese
word for word plural you saw charbel
yesterday in MSA
word for word question marker dual form
you saw charbel in the yesterday first
note that the MSA sentence begins with a
yes or no question marker Hal this isn't
used in Lebanese there's a different yes
or no question marker in Lebanese that
can be used she which comes after the
verb or at the end of the sentence but
it's not here in this example next
notice the different verbs meaning to
see shifter is a form of the verb which
is the common word meaning to see or
look at and most if not all Arabic
dialects the word exists in MSA but
normally with the meaning of to look
down over or to view the usual word for
C in MSA is
incidentally if you know some Hebrew you
probably notice that it's a cognate of
the Hebrew word meaning to see here the
verb is conjugated in the past tense
second person dual form a special form
used when talking about two people or
things for more than two people the
regular plural form would be used in
this case in the masculine
in the feminine Lebanese doesn't have
dual forms and uses the plural for pairs
of people or things I should be clear
that I'm talking about verb forms in
Lebanese there are dual forms for nouns
it's also worth noting that Lebanese
plural forms have no distinction between
masculine and feminine while in MSA they
have different forms
notice the word for yesterday
which is used throughout the Levant
region and Egypt with slightly varying
pronunciation it comes from the standard
word
which means last night in MSA the usual
word for yesterday is
yesterday it's interesting to note that
in some Lebanese dialects specifically
in the South the word is used with the
meaning of recently it comes from the
word amps
as we've seen Lebanese Arabic is
different in a number of ways from
Modern Standard Arabic some Lebanese
people go so far as to say that it's not
Arabic but rather a descendant of
Aramaic which has adopted Arabic
vocabulary the way English has adopted
many words from French to me it seems
like there's simply an Aramaic
substratum the influence of Aramaic as
its speakers began to adopt Arabic as
their main language it's interesting to
note that most Arabic dialects share a
lot of features in common that are
different from that suggests that Arabic
dialects didn't develop from fusa which
is literary but rather from a colloquial
form of Arabic which was used alongside
it in the 7th Century in any case
Lebanese and the other levantine
dialects are definitely fun and
interesting varieties of colloquial
Arabic and learning one of them
alongside Modern Standard Arabic would
definitely be a great choice if you're a
speaker of Lebanese Arabic or another
levantine dialect what other features or
words from your dialect would you like
us to know write your ideas in the
comments down below
if you're learning Arabic there's a
special and unique program that I think
you should check out it's called talk in
Arabic and it's the only place where you
can learn any of the major dialects of
spoken Arabic they have lessons
resources and HD videos covering each
variety so you can focus on whichever
variety you're learning but you can also
gain exposure to the other varieties
build an awareness of the differences
and improve your listening comprehension
of spoken Arabic in general to check out
talk in Arabic click the link in the
description you can use my code
langfocus for a 10 discount off any plan
I'd like to give a shout out to all of
the langfocus patreon supporters whose
support makes educational content like
this possible the people whose names you
see on the screen are the top tier
patreon supporters so let's give a round
of applause and a big thank you to them
if you liked this video and you want to
see more click the thumbnail to check
out my playlist on the Arabic language
you'll find out about other dialects how
similar Arabic is to other languages how
Arabic has influenced other languages
and lots more